si la parole est un monsieur bernard et
monsieur le premier ministre hier pour
la quatrième fois du quinquennat vous
avez décidé d'utiliser l'article 49 3 de
la constitution afin de faire adopter
sans que les députés en débatte un texte
que vous aviez présenté comme un grand
est très formateur
pourtant ce projet de loi n'est plus que
l'ombre de lui même la quasi-totalité
des mesures positives ont été
abandonnées et il est devenu de
renoncement en renoncement en tête seul
contraire aux intérêts de nos petites et
moyennes entreprises
ce texte devait réformer en profondeur
le code du travail
mais s'il se limite à une simple
giratoire constants il devrait porter
une flexisécurité à la française
mais les mesures d'assouplissement de
l'organisation du travail ont été
retirés il devait fluidifier les
relations sociales au sein de
l'entreprise
mais seul le monopole syndical on
ressort aujourd'hui renforcée que vous
soyez contraint d'engager la
responsabilité du gouvernement sur un
projet de loi qui ne comporte plus
aucune ambition de réformes témoigne de
l'impasse dans laquelle françois
hollande a mené notre pays
à force de laisser aller et
d'immobilisme votre bilan est
catastrophique et vous n'avez plus de
majorité pour gouverner la france va de
plus en plus mal et vos promesses ne
sont pas tenues pour le chômage pour la
croissance pour le déficit pour la dette
qui explose
la situation de la france justifie des
réformes profondes que le gouvernement
est incapable de porter alors monsieur
le premier ministre
sans confiance et sans crédibilité êtes
vous encore en mesure de gouverner
gouverner jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle
ou bien cette dernière étape du mandat
sera t-elle une année pour rien une
année inutile
jusqu'à ce que les français aient bien
attendre le changement que nous répond
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
bernard perrut quelle caricature
pour ceux qui en doutent encore s'il ya
des différences entre la droite et la
gauche
il faut bien évidemment vous écouter
quelle caricature
comment osez-vous quand le président de
la république dit ça va mieux ça va
mieux bien évidemment nous le savons
pour beaucoup de français
en effet il ya beaucoup de difficultés
mais il ya quand même quelques
indicateurs
ça va mieux qu'en 2012 le chômage des
jeunes avait progressé depuis 30 %
durant les années près cinq années
précédant ça va mieux qu'en 2012 ou la
dette publique a augmenté de plus de 600
milliards d'euros ça va mieux qu'en 2012
ou le taux d'investissement de 12 ans
lui a laissé pluie dans le hall des
mystiques long sur l'égal de 2012 le
pouvoir ça s'est amélioré version de la
jeune du projet loi travail quelle
caricature encore nous n'avons pas et
gelé suffisamment assumé ici nous
n'avons pas une vision manichéenne du
monde de l'entreprise
nous pensons qu'il faut de nouvelles
formes de régulation nous pensons en
effet que les entreprises à pouvoir
mieux s'adapter mieux s'adapter pour
renforcer la compétitivité de notre
économie mais nous sommes pas comme vous
dans un projet qui serait de faire fi
des syndicats fille les partenaires
sociaux nous nous assumons de renforcer
le rôle des syndicats au sein de
l'entreprise
parce que par la négociation nous avons
amélioré les souplesses et puis par
ailleurs quelle caricature
nous avons une restructuration des
branches professionnelles dans ce projet
loi nous avons des ailes en direction
des tpe des provisions pour charges
nous avons mis en place l'aide embauche
pme 270 mille entreprises qui ont pu en
bénéficier
monsieur le député bernard perrut cesser
ses propos outranciers
vous savez pertinemment ce qu'il y a
dans ce projet de loi puisque vous y
avez particulièrement travaillé et nous
avons d'ailleurs fait attention à
d'apprendre 469 amendements des
parlementaires parce que justement ils
sont là pour enrichir ce projet loi mais